is darling bernie sanders finally
breaking his silence on cuba
and of course he's taking a shot at
america bernie going soft on the
communist regime when
pressed on it last year during the
campaign
you said that it's unfair to simply say
everything is bad
in cuba do you still share that
sentiment
now that the people there seem to be
well i support
throughout latin america and in cuba and
every place else the right of people to
protest
for a decent economy and for political
freedom
and bernie's response wouldn't be
complete without blaming america
instead of decades of a communist
dictatorship he tweeted this quote
it's also long past time to end the
unilateral u.s embargo on cuba which has
only hurt not help the cuban people
okay i'll go to you greg okay talk about
the fact that
the people in cuba who are protesting uh
allegedly are protesting uh over covet
according to the cuban uh
cuban uh uh uh what what is the services
the services whatever the government is
it really about covert oh of course not
it's
it's kovit just brings out the worst in
a in a doomed society
but for sanders it's hard to condemn
something or an idea that you praise for
almost your entire life
it goes back to the enemy of
intellectual growth which is the sunk
cost if you're if you've invested 70
years of your life
in an idea that destroys entities once
they adopt it it's kind of hard
it's a little late for bernie to turn
that truck around i mean it's like this
it is the ideological equivalent of a
money pit
you can't stop putting money into it
bernie denouncing cuba would be like
cnn denouncing fake news that's your
brand
jessie denouncing hair gel you know
dana denouncing jasper me denouncing
raw sensuality that was a great answer
thank you all right you know the
democrats socialists of america seem to
be backing
uh you know the the claim that they're
over there not protesting about freedom
but they're protesting about
other things like the economy well then
they should take spanish
class because libertad which is what
they're all clamoring for
means liberty and freedom and that's
what they're asking for and actually if
you do just a little bit of research on
it um
for those socialists out there you can
see that it was really from the
grassroots and it really started with a
lot of artists
including um a rap artist who was like
i'm just gonna go forward because
they're sick of it
they're tired of it and they want the
help and i don't think that
the i think well i the good news is for
the cubans that bernie is not biden and
biden is the president of the united
states
i don't think that biden is exactly
where obama was
on this remember obama wanted like full
normalized relations
and the embargo do all these things
president trump walks this back
i don't think biden will actually go
back to the obama version because
one they saw what happened when they
squashed or didn't help
the revolution in iran and they don't
want that to happen here in cuba like
you can't do that to people there
the discouraging thing is that the
internet has been
shut down and communication has all kind
of stopped
there so if there's anyone out there
that has the technology that would allow
these people to be able to communicate
with each other it's good
the other bad news is apparently a lot
of these dissidents that were jailed
um are being treated terribly right and
there ought to be consequences for that
too
yeah just it's true they are being
treated terribly and we just found out
that
there are more than 100 missing or
arrested and
one included a journalist uh you know
what what
what should we be doing in the situation
well we don't have a great track record
of uh dealing with that
regime so i don't know what we could do
every attempt we've made to overthrow
that regime has backfired so i think
this might be a time where you want to
wait it out but i want to talk
about bernie sanders here just a little
history lesson the reason we have the
embargo against cuba
is because the soviets put missiles in
cuba ballistic missiles pointed at the
united states
[Music]
they're 90 miles off the shore of key
west you just think that's okay like
let's just drop the embargo
and all of the enemies of america just
to send missiles to cuba
and point it at washington d.c that's
why bernie sanders is dangerously stupid
does bernie really believe that
communism would work if we just dropped
the embargo
no the regime is just going to pilfer
all the stuff
and they're going to basically use
patronage to set up a permanent
and never-ending authoritarian regime
here's what bernie and this is to
greg's point here here's what bernie is
saying he never actually addresses the
fact that people in these communist
countries
hate it they they're suffering he never
talks about that he always talks about
theoretical communism and theoretical
socialism and that's because he's
arrogant
and he believes that communism or
socialism
would work in this country and the
people would like it if just bernie
sanders
could administer it and that's the
fallacy yeah and he actually said it was
working in venezuela until it wasn't
then he had to take it off the senate
website but what about the squad squad's
kind of quiet on this one
i can't speak for him i don't know why
uh i have not been president biden has
not been
um i agree with everything that's been
said and there's no excuse you have a
decaying
corrupt and communist regime uh 90 miles
off our shore i think at some level we
ought to step back and even ponder that
question a bit but anybody in their
right mind can't support what's
happening there and has to be supportive
of these protesters to jesse's point it
may take
this could be one of those tipping point
moments where the people decide they
want this
and i think we'd have to decide how we
want to be helpful if we could
and if we could be constructive and
helping finally if you look at the
entire region
right you look at our entire hemisphere
one of the reasons i believe as much as
we spend money
in other hemispheres around the globe to
try to stabilize things than we should
we spend very little here and we have to
think about think about that in a
meaningful way
take bernie out of it take the squad out
of it think about it from a foreign
policy
and national security standpoint that's
a great point it really is
thank you i don't know about you but i'm
getting really hot in here hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else